[Music]
today we cancel once again
cnn uh this time for a segment on the
kyle rittenhouse case featuring one mr
jeffrey toobin as you recall though you
surely wish you did not recall
tubin cnn legal analyst gained
international notoriety last year when
he was caught
uh badgering the witness during a zoom
meeting with his co-workers toobin
tubin pulled his tube out you might say
he tried to to put a gently uh get a
hold of himself during this meeting he's
always been a self-congratulatory type
so he decided to give himself a hand so
to speak and while he was engaged in
this diy project his colleagues looked
on in
unimaginable shock and heart
now for most humans on earth
handling your situation in a work
setting in full view of other employees
would lead not only to immediate
termination but it would likely
foreclose all future possibilities of
employment
you could maybe get a job as assistant
manager at your local sex shop i don't
know though on second thought you
certainly could not be trusted in that
setting either so really that would be
it for you
you may never find gainful employment
ever again but jeffrey toobin works in
corporate media and the roles rules are
different there which means that in this
case he was back on the beat with uh cnn
within just a few months cnn has mostly
not seen it necessary to justify its
decision to employ and provide a public
platform to a man who masturbated during
a work meeting to the extent that
they've bothered to explain it the
rationale seems to be that tuban's
behavior was an accident
he's the real victim here you see
he didn't know that his camera was on
during the zoom call he thought he was
uh debugging the hard drive in the
privacy of his own home and it may
indeed be true that he didn't know the
camera was on
but
the act itself was not an accident
granted i was not on the call which is
why i still have eyes and i haven't
gouged them out
but i still feel safe assuming that
tubin didn't slip and fall and
accidentally masturbate no he quite
intentionally decided to perform that
act during a work meeting
while watching his co-workers
the only thing he didn't intend was for
them to know that he was doing it
i fail to see how that makes this any
better
i mean if there's a guy
on public transportation sitting in the
back of the bus masturbating
hoping no one sees it someone does can
he say to the cop well i didn't mean for
anyone to know that i was doing it
especially because we can assume here
as always is the case in this kind of
situation that when a pervert is caught
in the act for the first time
he was only caught for the first time
it's not however his first time at the
rodeo
and yet he's back on the air which leads
us finally to this segment and uh let's
all watch cautiously
jeffrey two thoughts two thoughts one
what kind of idiot
seventeen-year-old gets a giant gun and
goes to a riot he has no license he has
no training he thinks he's going to
scrub graffiti off with his ar-15 i mean
the stupidity of this like what could
possibly go wrong well a lot went wrong
the good news for kyle rittenhouse is
that he's not on trial for being an
idiot he's on trial for homicide and in
that respect i mostly agree with joey
that
this is a tough case for the prosecution
because
it does seem like
he has a plausible case of self-defense
and you know if
if it were illegal to be an idiot the
jails would be even freer
even more crowded than they are now
homicide's a different matter
very bold move by cnn to use a glass
table um
also you have to feel bad for the guy
sitting right next to tubin
as tube is kind of waving his hands
around like that
his life must been flashing before his
eyes which is still better than tuban
flashing before his eyes i suppose as
for two but he accuses rittenhouse of
being an idiot
now just to emphasize here the man who
pleasured himself during a zoom meeting
and forgot to turn the camera off is
calling somebody else an idiot
he says it's fortunate for rittenhouse
that you know being an idiot isn't
illegal well it's fortunate for tubin
that masturbating in front of unwilling
spectators isn't illegal oh wait it is
illegal
just not if you're a member of the
favored class
now putting his childish analysis of the
written house case aside i mean you can
really see why cnn just had to bring the
masturbator back on the air because
otherwise they'd be deprived of
insightful legal opinions like that
guy's an idiot lol
but putting that aside
jeffrey tubin really shows us the nature
of cancel culture doesn't he
jeffrey tubin shows us quite a lot
actually way more than we want to see
but the lesson he provides about cancel
culture is useful cancel culture is as i
always said
arbitrary by definition why is louis c.k
still banished to the cultural
hinterlands persona non grata and yet
tubin is on cable news they did the same
thing but tuban is arguably worse
because he didn't get consent ahead of
time
and there have certainly been people who
committed far less severe infractions or
no infraction and yet suffered
punishments far worse than whatever
tuban suffered which was really nothing
at all when it comes to workplace sexual
harassment specifically we live in a
world now where giving your female
co-worker a compliment may be sexual
harassment but i mean in in tubin's case
masturbating in front of her during a
work meeting is not sexual harassment
but this is all by design it's a power
move by cnn really
cancer culture is arbitrary it's also
left-wing inherently
it was largely invented by the left-wing
corporate media it's their thing
canceled culture belongs to cnn and its
fellow corporate media organizations it
will decide who is canceled and who is
not
jeffrey tubin is on their team
they happen to like him for whatever
reason and so they will grant him a pass
that nobody else i mean nobody else on
the planet anywhere would be granted
there's no coherent moral philosophy
underpinning this cancel culture isn't
is it it's not it's not mere left-wing
puritanism
it's not even a moral panic
it's a weapon
and they will decide how to wield it
that's why tubin still has a job
and it's probably still invited on zoom
calls
and everybody else in the call just has
to make sure that they don't eat lunch
beforehand i guess
that's also why i must say again today
that cnn is of course
cancelled
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated